look at that trophy shinin bright Billy
Ray Cyrus little nods X c'mon show him
off musical event of the year for Old
Town Road how are you guys celebrating
tonight I'll just be an air seeing so
many people that I'm a fan of my friends
you know it's all a celebration of music
I just want to like you know say like
these are performances have been like
amazing and just like I've been getting
goosebumps all night goosebumps holding
that award right there in your hand
definitely you know obviously there was
a lot of controversy surrounding this
song at the beginning and now that you
have a Country Music Award in your hand
what do you have to say to the haters
have you said we hold this in our hand
there's really not anything we need to
say that this song was about the fans
and the people that loved the song it
wasn't really about people that had
other opinions it was for the fans it
wasn't for the critics it was a it's a
song of people sang they danced it was
something that people could find in
common with each other and it's been
quite a ride to be a part of this
phenomenon I'm with him on that one
no Billy did you ever think we're
approaching the 28 year anniversary of
achy-breaky heart did you ever think a
song would top the success of that song
like this one half not really to be
honest I mean thank you break it was a
huge record and I don't know I didn't
think anything would whatever like that
but this thing has been a wild ride ya
know I think you two should do a remix
of achy-breaky heart I've been getting
that a lot you know I'm down I'm down
but we want to make something original I
think next you guys are still down to
work together and keep it going I love
this guy Manny he's a good guy he's a
good man and also he's he's a genius man
he's a thinker he he wasn't thinking
like inside the box outside the box he
was thinking like there is no box and
that's what I say to all the dreamers
anyone who has a dream you live life
don't try to fit in - what's the norm
you you go outside and just being a
ridge
that's what this guy is he's an original
how proud would you say you are of
Lowell Nozick I'm so proud of him I'd
say he's like my my adopted son if not
my real son you know what I mean like I
love him so much and he he's just he's
just a great human being I love being
around him being in the crowd and seeing
how people gravitate to him and they
smile he's got an electricity and a
charisma that's contagious
I feel like y'all need to hug it out now
hug it out
[Music]